hello my name is Tony Daley and I'm from
Birmingham
[Applause]
my promise journey today the usual thing
where I've gotten a mortgage letter as a
very very youngster a usual thing one to
try and pay my mortgage off my
circumstance has changed up to that 20
years ago I sold my property at the
present moment now and I'm have some
little money to want to invest and make
the most of it
I signed at 16th Escala for Villa and 17
and made my debut for Aston Villa and
from then kicked on stayed over 10 years
in that time I won Le Coq with him
one has looked twice with them and
managed to play for my country which the
pinnacle of my career I'd left Villa
after 10 years and signed for vehicles
signing a time which was won a half a
million pounds walked onto Wanderers
which wasn't a good move for me simply
because I picked up I hope of injuries I
was there for four years I was injured
for the three years were there and that
makes you kind of think what you're
going to do the rest of your career and
and they use that time wisely property
is great to invest in for footballers
because of the the increment they've got
you know that that they can use it's an
ideal situation the turnovers
unbelievable if it's put in the right
places and have the right advice which
Sam can give its ID of ideal things to
make them financially sound
Sam's teaching style is excellent it's
very relaxed but it gives you straight
you know there's this dump there's no
mixing of words he wants to be clear you
give them a question you want to be
really clear what that question means
you know and they'll put you in the
right direction of with the information
you need to know and footballers have
got a good income and you know are
they're put into the right thing and
doing the right things and this is an
ideal opportunity for them to go I'll be
certainly recommending the people I know
other footballers ex-football as well to
come along speak to him what would you
say fortunately blast but they're not
really possibly but have they know
quietens bro they're not seen what would
you say
come on you're on your horses
[Music]